unterwegs in wiesbaden die hessische
landeshauptstadt ist jetzt um 20
millionen euro ärmer alles steuergelder
von den bürgern der stadt wiesbaden
wollte das geld zurücklegen davon
irgendwann straßen oder kindergärten
bauen jetzt sind die millionen weg
das ist axel im holz seit jahren
kämmerer der stadt er ist verantwortlich
für die finanzen
morgen meeting mit markus zwei dem chef
der finanzierungs abteilung wiesbaden
gehört zu den reicheren städten des
landes
240 millionen haben im holz und sein
team auf der hohen kante
20 millionen davon hat er als festgeld
bei der greens il bank eingezahlt
wir haben einen termin mit dem kämmerer
vereinbart und wollen wissen wie kam er
auf greencell warum hat er das geld
gerade dort angelegt
[Musik]
wir hatten jetzt im letzten jahr 200
millionen angelegt in termingeldern wenn
wir das nicht getan hätten sondern ist
bei unserer hausbank das ist die
sparkasse deponiert hätten
während dort 0 5% verwarnt geld also
strafzins fällig gewesen einfache
rechnung 200 millionen mal 0 5 prozent
sind eine millionen euro pro jahr
die uns nur deshalb verloren gehen weil
wir das geld bei der sparkasse abgelegt
haben im holz ist dem lockruf der zinsen
gefolgt greencell hat 0,25 prozent
versprochen
andere banken kassieren zur gleichen
zeit 0,5 prozent strafzinsen wenn man
dort geld parkt hätte er da nicht
stutzig werden müssen
wir fragen nach an der universität
gießen die wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin
christina bahn gewandt der markt hat
nichts zu verschenken
[Musik]
werden hohe zinsen geboten wird eine
hohe rendite geboten dann muss es ein
großes risiko im hintergrund stehen nach
diesem risiko muss ich schauen
ich muss es versuchen zu verstehen mir
erklären können und ich muss mich fragen
kann ich dieses risiko tragen oder kann
ich es manager wiesbadens kämmerer weiß
den verdacht leichtsinnig gehandelt zu
haben von sich sein amt habe alle
kennzahlen gewissenhaft geprüft sagt im
holz er sieht fehler bei der staatlichen
finanzaufsicht der bafin
wir fahren nach frankfurt die ihr geht
kämmerer uwe becker anders mit den
steuergeldern um
er ist seit 14 jahren im amt
frankfurts haushalt beträgt 4 milliarden
euro die überschüsse investiert becker
direkt wieder straßen schulen
historische häuser so hat frankfurt nur
wenige rücklagen aber auch becker legt
steuergelder bei banken an
seit werden jahren haben wir unsere
anlagepolitik verschärft das heißt ich
habe sehr viel wert darauf gelegt auf
eine sehr konservative anlagestrategie
wir legen sofort bei sparkassen
volksbanken an dann bei banken die
überhaupt nur im aaa-rating gekleidet
sind
becker und sein team haben der
verlockung des schnellen geldes
widerstanden
er hat lieber negativzinsen in kauf
genommen und so das steuergeld der
bürger gerettet
doch auch becker sieht die
finanzaufsicht in der pflicht sie habe
bei greenville zu spät gehandelt sagte
er ich verstehe natürlich dass eine
bafin nicht automatisch jeder
ermittlungen öffentlich auf den markt
gehen kann das wird ja auch ein surfer
für den koffer sie das als negative
nachrichten führen dann hier erst recht
dazu das institut in ein schlechtes
licht rücken
aber es brauchen instrumentarium was
früher aufzeigt dass vielleicht ein
geschäftsgebaren nicht in ordnung oder
risikobehafteter ist rund 40 städte und
gemeinden haben greenhill geld
überwiesen
die liste der geschädigten ist lang
die gemeinde pöcking mit ihrem gut 5000
einwohnern beispielsweise gibt fünf
millionen köln überweist 15 millionen
und das land thüringen investiert sogar
50 millionen euro
unterwegs nach bremen
hier hatte die greens il bank ihren sitz
wir wollen wissen wie ging es zu in der
bank der so viele städte und gemeinden
millionensummen anvertraut haben
die büros sind verlassen und leer doch
bis zum märz drehen die bremer banker
hier das große finanzrat
130 mitarbeiter 4,5 milliarden
jahresumsatz greencell ist agil die
kunden liste wird immer länger und die
ratingagenturen die festlegen ob eine
bank seriös ist geben greencell top
bewertungen
[Musik]
die bank sei auf dem papier tatsächlich
teilweise sehr gut aus die
eigenkapitalfinanzierung war enorm stark
sehr solide dank kapitalspritzen des
mutterunternehmens
im märz 2021 ist der zauber vorbei
die deutsche finanzaufsicht die bafin
stoppt das geschäft
die größte bankenpleite der letzten
jahre ist perfekt die finanzwelt schaut
auf die insolvente greencell bank
jahrelang hatte die bremer greencell
bank verlockend hohe zinsen angeboten
das insolvenzverfahren ist eröffnet und
die kunden fürchten um ihr geld
es riecht nach bilanzfälschung das
riecht nach wirecard und darf insidern
insgesamt etwa 500 millionen euro
die städte hoffen jetzt dass sie
zumindest einen teil ihrer anlagen
erstattet bekommen
wir sind zu gast in der kanzlei nieding
und barth klaus nieding einer der
renommiertesten anlegeranwälte des
landes ist der jäger der verlorenen
steuergelder
er kämpft für rund die hälfte der
betroffenen städte haben jetzt über 20
städte und gemeinden die wir vertreten
und die gesamte schadenssumme liegt bei
etwa 90 millionen euro
nieding befürchtet aber es werde schwer
die steuergelder zurück zu bekommen
er rechnet mit einer prozessdauer von
mindestens drei jahren
denn es sei ein kampf an vielen fronten
da kommen natürlich die bank
beziehungsweise ihre manager ins
fadenkreuz aufsichtsräte vorstände
es kommen die wirtschaftsprüfer ins
fadenkreuz man muss wie bei wirecard
auch die frage stellen hat der
wirtschaftsprüfer bestimmte dinge
gesehen oder nicht gesehen
man muss natürlich nach der rolle der
aufsicht der bafin fragen haben die
deutschen fahnder nicht streng genug
nach london geschaut
hier ist die heimat von greencell
capital
das ist das mutterhaus der bremer bank
das unternehmen wird in london als eines
der erfolgreichsten start ups gefeiert
2018 ist es 1,6 milliarden dollar wert
und das ist der kopf hinter dem
gesamtunternehmen lex greencell sohn
eines rohzucker fahrers aus australien
mit 24 zieht er nach london und arbeitet
als investmentbanker 2011 macht er sich
selbstständig dann geht alles ganz
schnell
die zahl der mitarbeiter steigt in
wenigen monaten von 40 auf 130 und die
bilanzen der bank explodieren
von 2017 bis 2019 vereinfacht sich das
ergebnis eine außergewöhnliche
erfolgsgeschichte
prinz charles schlägt queen zum ritter
wegen seiner verdienste um die
wirtschaft und david cameron
der ehemalige regierungschef steht auf
der gehaltsliste als mächtiger türöffner
green hills geschäft das ist die
finanzierung von lieferketten
ein beispiel ein unternehmer liefert
waren an einen kunden in südamerika bis
die rechnung für die lieferung bezahlt
wird dauert es meist viele wochen hier
springt greencell ein und zahlt die
rechnung sofort dafür kassiert das
unternehmen eine provision
die folge je mehr geschäfte greencell
abschließt desto mehr geld ist nötig
denn die deals müssen vorfinanziert
werden
das rad dreht sich immer schneller
was genau bei greencell schieflief
wollen wir hier in erfahrung bringen
zurück in frankfurt der deutschen
finanzmetropole
[Musik]
hier treffen wir den finanzjournalisten
christian kirchner
[Musik]
er kennt sich aus in der bankenszene hat
sich über monate mit dem thema green
city beschäftigt ist mit sicherheit
einer der größten bankenpleiten der
letzten 15 jahre für die bank hatte am
schluss nur bilanzsumme von 400
milliarden das ist nicht so groß es ist
eine mittelgroße städtische sparkasse
was den fall aber so besonders macht ist
traurig dass eine ganze menge gläubiger
auf ihrem schaden sitzen bleiben werden
die bruchlandung hätte man vermeiden
können sagt kirchner
denn es gab bereits frühzeitig alarm
signale dafür dass etwas faul ist in der
bank im büro zeigt uns christian
kirchner dokumente die er zum fall
greencell gesammelt hat den
geschäftsbericht der greencell bank
beispielsweise ertragslage die risiken
aus gesetzlichen gründen muss das alles
veröffentlicht werden
ich hab sofort beim ersten blick in den
geschäftsberichten sehen dass die bank
ein irres rad dreht das habe ich
eigentlich so in der form noch nie
gesehen bei einer bank die es schon eine
ganze weile gibt das hört sich die
bilanzsumme dermaßen aufgebläht wird in
kürzester zeit
der geschäftsbericht ist im
bundesanzeiger frei verfügbar
auch die kämmerer hätten dort
reinschauen und alarmsignale erkennen
können sagt uns der finanzexperte schon
im frühjahr 2020 vermutet die bafin dass
etwas nicht stimmt doch es dauert noch
monate bis die bank geschlossen wird die
erste mitteilung die die bafin gemacht
hat das moratorium das die fragen hat
hat sie unter anderem mit dem kaum
kaschierten vorwort versehen dass hier
möglicherweise knall hatte betrug im
spiel sein könnte also da schreibt sie
der nachweis für bestimmte forderungen
konnte nicht erbracht werden
wir ziehen zwischenbilanz von der green
zellbank lassen sich rund 40 städte und
gemeinden und ein bundesland ködern
sie legen steuergelder in millionenhöhe
an hat greencell bei der finanzierung
von lieferketten getrickst und was hat
die finanzaufsicht wann genau gewusst
dazu wollen wir mehr erfahren
st gallen in der schweiz professor erik
hofmann lehrt seit jahren an der
renommierten wirtschaftsuniversität hsc
auf dem rosenberg hofmann gilt als
experte im bereich supply chain
management
das finanzieren von lieferketten das war
genau das geschäft von greencell
professor hoffmann erklärt uns
lieferketten sind eigentlich seriös und
sicher es gibt klare verträge zwischen
dem lieferanten und dem abnehmer
wenn die bank das geld für die
finanzierung nicht zurückbekommt springt
eine warenkreditversicherung 1
doch irgendwann kommen geschäfte dazu
die es nur auf dem papier gibt
sogenannte future deals die in der
zukunft stattfinden
vielleicht aber auch nie
man spricht aktuell von future receiver
birds die finanziert werden dh
möglicherweise gab es ein vertrag
zwischen lieferanten abnehmer aber die
warenlieferung jetzt noch gar nicht
stattgefunden weil sie mir zukunft keine
waren keine rechnungen und entsprechend
keine zahlungen und das hat dazu geführt
dass die warenkreditversicherung
rausgegangen ist durch den ausstieg der
versicherung kommt alles ins rutschen
greencell hat risikofreie abgesicherte
geldanlagen versprochen doch vergeben
wurden ungesicherte darlehen dann wenige
großkunden
genau hier scheint dann auch
entsprechend das problem gelegen zu
haben dass unter dem deckmantel der
supply chain finanzierung der
lieferketten finanzierung auch andere
geschäfte gelaufen sind die aber nicht
so heißen nämlich darlehen professor
hofmann zeigt uns wie komplex das green
zulieferketten modell aufgebaut ist
deshalb war es schwierig
unregelmäßigkeiten zu erkennen
nein hat er nicht also das ist viel zu
komplex und er muss es ja auch nicht
es hat hier genügend akteure in dem
spiel die für ihn diesen überblick denn
auch und die risiken die dort enthalten
sind für ihn prüfen ja nun die deutsche
finanzaufsicht also profis können die
sollten wir denn dieses modell
überblicken kann ja genau das ist genau
er natürlich ihre aufgabe er hat dieses
konstrukt zu überblicken und etwaige
risiken oder gar noch schlimmeres denn
auch aufzudecken hat die deutsche
bankenaufsicht versagt nach vielen
telefonaten bekommen wir bei der bafin
ein interview mit dem obersten
bankenaufseher des landes
[Musik]
raimund röseler ist der herr über 1500
banken
er schickt anfang 2020 erst nach einem
tipp britischer kollegen fahren dann
nach bremen
die bank hat von anfang an ganz stark
gemauert es war nicht in der lage uns
dokumente zu liefern wo man erwartet
dass die vorlegen darlehensverträge
verträge von den zugrunde liegenden
geschäften alles das wurde uns nicht
gezeigt das macht uns natürlich erst
recht misstrauisch
wir haben dann den druck erhöht haben
dann sukzessive einzelner unterlagen
bekommen die haben wir dann auch
verrennt sich untersuchen lassen also
wirklich gestimmt schriftbild stimmte
entstehungsdatum mit dem was uns gesagt
worden ist aber ein röseler und sein
team prüfen die unterlagen monatelang
dann sind sie sicher forderungen die in
den greencell bilanzen stehen gibt es
gar nicht im märz 2021 zieht er den
stecker
aber warum hat die bafin die deutschen
städte nicht früher gewarnt
ganz einfach werden und strafbar gemacht
wir unterliegen strenge vertraulichkeit
rege und wir dürfen es nicht sagen dass
die strafbewehrte davon abgesehen jeder
kämmerer hätte nummer google müssten und
hätte gesehen im google dass wir da
aktiv sind
jeder kämmerer der bisschen recherchiert
hätte auch gesehen dass die green
zielgruppe in england probleme als
wirtschaftsprüfer zu finden das sollte
eigentlich professionellen anleger zum
nachdenken bringen der bankenaufseher
sieht die schuld für die verlorenen
steuergelder bei den kämmerern
seine behörde sei richtig vorgegangen
sagt röseler
wir haben sehr schnell gehandelt wir
haben richtig gehandelt nach 1 sind
natürlich im nachhinein muss man sagen
wir hätten uns bei der vergabe des
prüfungsauftrag es vielleicht noch mal
bei allen sollen dann hätten wir zwei
drei wochen gespart mehr weil es aber
nicht gewesen
das sehen nicht alle so gerhard schick
war 13 jahre lang bundestagsabgeordneter
der grünen jetzt ist der anerkannte
finanzexperte her sagt hätte die
bankenaufsicht schneller gehandelt wären
steuergelder in millionenhöhe gerettet
worden
die bafin hat sie später agiert das
große wachstum bei den einlagen bis 2019
da hat sich also offensichtlich das
geschäftsmodell der insel deutlich
verändert und dann hat es zu lange
gedauert bis sich die bafin einen
überblick verschafft hat woran das
eigentlich lex greencell drohen
strafrechtliche konsequenzen
denn es geht um betrug bilanzfälschung
luftbuchungen und die verschleierung von
anlagerisiken
weltweit wollen geschädigte ihr geld
zurück das gesamtunternehmen ist bereits
zerschlagen
eine pleite mit vielen verlierern selbst
die privatkunden sind betroffen wenn
auch nur indirekt
[Musik]
wir sind in berlin private anleger die
bei green ziel investiert haben bekommen
ihr geld zwar über den
einlagensicherungsfonds erstattet dort
zahlen die banken ein
aber sie holen sich das geld zurück
termin beim bundesverband der banken
[Musik]
wir treffen hilmar zettler den chef der
deutschen einlagensicherung der vor
hilft den anlegern bei einer
bankenpleite der fall greencell hat die
rücklagen arg strapaziert die grenze
pleite ist schon erheblich sowohl für
unsere freiwillige wie auch die
gesetzliche einlagensicherung
wir haben es hier mit einem
gesamtschaden von über drei milliarden
euro zu tun und reden damit über den
zweitgrößten einlagensicherungs fall den
wir bislang gehabt haben nach lehman
brothers die schäden durch die greencell
pleite sind groß mehr als 21.000 privat
sparer haben bereits ihr geld
zurückbekommen geschützt sind einlagen
bis zu 100.000 euro
jetzt sind die köpfe leer und müssen von
den beteiligten banken aufgefüllt werden
die zeche zahlen die bankkunden wie die
bank ihre kosten weiter leiden ist
natürlich geschäftspolitische
entscheidung das können wir nicht
beurteilen aber natürlich diese drei
milliarden euro müssen irgendwo
finanziert werden das heißt die banken
müssen natürlich schauen wo sie diese
gelder wieder reinholen können
letztlich kommt das was die privaten
banken verloren haben über die
einlagensicherung natürlich auch wieder
bei den kunden der privaten banken an
erhöhte gebühren oder schlechte
konditionen
unsere recherche reise geht zu ende
was sind die lehren aus der greencell
pleite offenbar haben kriminelle banker
das anlegervertrauen ausgenutzt haben
die finanzaufseher zu schwach gehandelt
erheblich tapfere aggressivere
finanzaufsicht die schneller und früher
nachgeht vor der die banken auch zittern
wenn sie einmarschiert ist wirecard
jetzt greencell und die bafin verspricht
wieder einmal sieben schlagkräftiger
werden
also noch viel stärker eine
geschäftsmodell der banken einsteigen
etablieren deswegen neue einheiten für
die sogenannte fokus auf sicht und
werden dass frank hiermit neigen
ich glaube dann sind wir wirklich
schlagkräftig doch die aufseher
benötigen nicht nur eine eigene task
force wegen der weltweiten verflechtung
von unternehmen brauchen sie einen
globaleren blick die fiese der queen
soll bank war ja auch eine krise in der
abstimmung zwischen der bank und ihrem
mutterunternehmen der green soll kempter
und diese verflechtungen die müssen
aufseher im auge haben die globalen
wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen
das ist der job der bankenaufsicht die
bafin hat zwar gehandelt aber mit
schnelleren prüfungen hätte sie
steuergelder in millionenhöhe retten
können
das lehrgeld zahlen die steuerzahler
[Musik]